nach dem anschlag von hanau wird zum
schutz der bevölkerung in ganz
deutschland die polizeipräsenz erhöht
bundesinnenminister seehofer kündigte an
dass sensible einrichtungen wie
insbesondere moscheen verstärkt
überwacht würden ebenso bahnhöfe und
flughäfen
insgesamt wächst die entschlossenheit
gegen rechte gesinnung vorzugehen
spd-generalsekretär klingbeil fördert
eine beobachtung der afd durch den
verfassungsschutz
hand in hand gegen rechten terror und im
gedenken an die opfer von hanno gut 500
menschen kommen zur mahnwache am
brandenburger tor gestern abend neben
etlichen spitzenpolitikern setzen viele
bürger mit ihrer teilnahme ein zeichen
gegen hass und gewalt dunkler tag für
uns heute hier in deutschland der mich
sehr mitgenommen hat und das möchte ich
zeigen
die politiker sollten ihre aufgaben sehr
gut machen einfach nicht sagen es tut
uns leid und es geht weiter die sonne
vernünftig was unternehmen wie und was
kann politik unternehmen
die bundesjustizministerin und der
bundesinnenminister versuchen darauf
antworten zu finden
erste konsequenz die polizeipräsenz wird
erhöht auch vor moscheen die
gefährdungslage durch rechtsextremismus
antisemitismus und rassismus ist in
deutschland sehr hoch
deshalb brauche es mehr konsequenz bei
der durchsetzung der geltenden gesetze
beispiel waffenrecht oder bei hass und
hetze im internet deswegen geht es jetzt
nicht darum gesetze zu verschärfen sowie
der kollege richtig gesagt hat sondern
wir werden genau hinschauen müssen ob
die gesetze die in kraft sind
ob die auch entsprechend ausgeführt
werden der terrorakt von hanau hat
deutschland schockiert politik und
gesellschaft suchen nach lösungen hass
und rechte gewalt wirksam zu bekämpfen